- Hey guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is the fifth PodSessions,
as many of you know.
By the way, if you've been wondering why
I've been throwing up my
entire hand in every photo,
that is 'cause it
represents the number five,
which is my favorite number.
If you haven't seen the video,
the Jets jersey my mom made for me,
literally Google Gary Vee mom Jets jersey.
You have to watch this video.
Number five has been my favorite
number since I turned five
and decided my favorite
number was gonna be my age.
That is the fun fact.
Starting PodSessions.
I'm very excited about this PodSession.
What I really wanna do first
and foremost is go round
the room and give
everybody who's listening
a little bit of who you
are and what you do.
Like, the five second
version of how you got there,
and then we'll go into it deeper.
Let's start, ladies
first, right over here.
- (laughs) Well, hello everybody.
My name is Arabella S.
Ruby, and I'm an actress
and a CEO of my own company.
I got my LLC in 2017,
January, Ruby Red Enterprise,
and yeah, it's been poppin' ever since.
- So, where are you from?
- I'm from Augusta, Georgia.
- [Gary] Very nice, born and raised?
- No, I was actually born in England.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
My mom was in the army for a while,
but I'm actually British
and Jamaican, so--
- Very cool.
So, your childhood in Georgia?
- [Arabella] Yes, majority of it--
- The masters would come
in for a couple of weeks--
- Yes, all of that, all of that.
(laughter)
Home of the 706.
- Yes, big ups for the 706.
So, you grew there, and you live here now?
- I live in New Jersey,
and I'm actually training--
- What part?
- Patterson.
- Love it, I know it well.
- Mmhmm.
And I am training to become
one of the best actresses
in the world in New York City.
- Ooh, jeez.
- Here we go.
- Keepin' it, (mumbling) ambition.
- I lived in Augusta,
Georgia from six to seven.
We just found that out,
she just found that out.
We were just chatting.
- I love my Augusta people.
- Very nice, jumping in
before being called on.
(laughter)
Nah, I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
Rich, Rich, let's fire away.
We'll get back to it.
- Great to be here, my name is Rich Roll.
I am a recovering attorney
turned ultra endurance athlete,
hosting podcasts that I've
been doing since 2012--
- Very successfully.
- Author, thank you.
- Successful in that as well.
- Thank you very much.
Contributed to Crushing It,
which I was very honored to do.
- And in the biggest way, for
everybody, in a couple weeks,
do we have the official date?
- [Man] Uh, no, I don't think so.
It's the third or the eighth.
- It's the third and or the eighth?
- Or the eighth.
- Good, I understand.
Friends, the audio book is finally coming.
August 3rd or 8th.
- April.
- Excuse me,
April 3rd or April 8th.
And Rich did me a real mitzvah.
For some of you that've read it,
there's stories of other
people who read Crush It
and then went on their way,
and are featured in Crushing It,
and Rich is one of
those people in the book
who was effected by Crush
and went onto Crushing It.
But he actually is the voice behind
the stories of the audio book.
I read most of it, and then
Amy, right, is the other voice.
Is that right, Amy?
(mumbling) Amy did the
other voices, right?
- Yes.
- So, I'm excited about that.
You were a very big part of Crushing It,
which is actually crushing it.
April 3rd?
April 3rd, it's like two seconds away.
- There it is.
- April 3rd, very excited.
- The feedback that I've gotten from being
in the book has been huge.
- Actually, I'll go back to it.
Alright, Rich, thrilled you're here.
You live on the west coast,
so you're here to do some business.
I'm glad you stopped by the PodSessions.
Gabe.
- Sup, my man?
- How are you?
- I'm excellent, how are you?
- [Gary] Good, who are you?
- Gabriel Anderson.
I actually run our VaynerBeta business,
which is our small and midmarket business.
I've been working alongside
Gary for five and half,
almost six years now.
Also from LA originally.
He pulled me out of my
startup from Santa Monica,
convinced me that what I
was doing was dog shit.
(laughter)
It'd be a lot better if I
come execute on a much bigger
platform and hasn't been wrong.
- And I really appreciate Gabe,
because Antonio Cromartie,
former star football
player and New York Jet
was supposed to be here,
but he's living the football
player life, fuckin' bailed.
Cro, I'm gonna find you.
But I can't wait to have you on.
So, I literally was like, well,
Gabe's fuckin' super interesting
and entertaining and,
I don't know, there he is, so,
let's have him on the show.
Actually, we're gonna start,
we're gonna go backwards.
Gabe, to make this a show, and honestly,
while you're on, 'cause I
know you won't be scared,
tell us a story that I
don't even know about me
from your five and a
half, tell me a story--
- Holy shit.
- When you go out to dinner--
- [Gabe] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Especially now that I'm
on the verge of becoming
the most famous person on earth,
you're gonna have to deal
with this more often.
(laughter)
And you have to deal with, you know,
you're gonna go out with your lovely girl
and you're gonna have
dinner and friends will go,
"Oh, you work for that guy?
"Tell me some story!"
What's a good story that you can go to?
Give me a story that I don't
even know, good or bad.
Just give me a funny story.
And you know my audience,
what's maybe a lesson,
or something to be more
specific, given this audience,
you know, I find you to
be very entrepreneurial.
You have your own story,
you've been here for a while,
you're crushing that with VaynerBeta.
Listen, for this audience,
you are the reason that
I finally feel confident that
we're about to help businesses
that really wanna work with me,
the SMBs, the startups, the entrepreneurs.
But what's a good story of
something you got taught
that was totally different
than the way you thought
about things, or just a funny story?
Like, give us a story.
- Yeah, so, the one that
immediately comes to mind is--
- And in story form, not
Gary taught me to be patient.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, no, no.
The story that immediately comes to mind,
I don't think you know
the full story of why
I came out to New York in the first place.
I had a startup and we were doing--
- Dog shit.
Back office transaction,
mostly management for realtors.
The way that I found out
about the business growing,
VaynerMedia growing, Gary sends
out a tweet late one night.
I think posted on Facebook as well.
It was just, VaynerMedia is growing,
we're looking for talented folks.
I'd followed him on YouTube
for about two, three years
up to that point, and
so I cold emailed him,
sent him off a bunch of spreadsheets.
It was a super long email.
Now knowing him now, I
know there's no fucking way
he read that email.
(laughter)
Nate, who was his
assistant back in the days,
now is hustling, doing his own thing,
probably read through the whole email.
- Nate was the admin at the time?
- Nate was the admin.
- Go get Nate.
- I sent him this really long
email with Excel spreadsheets
and the whole thing and
made this comment about,
do I have to be a Jets fan?
I still have it in my inbox,
it's the corniest thing.
This was 11.30 at night on the west coast,
so 1.30 in the morning in New York.
Gary emails me within five
minutes and he's like,
"Yep, I'm interested, let's chat.
"I want you to meet this
guy, Vikash, on my team.
"Talk with him, start out with him."
- Wasn't it 2.30 in the morning
if it was 11.30 your time?
- 11.30, 12.30, yeah, 2.30!
Yeah, 2.30 AM.
- Oh, Nate, real quick,
I know you're busy.
(Gabe laughs)
- Do you remember the email?
Do you think, Nate, he got his job,
do you think Gabe works
here only because of you?
- Yes.
(crosstalk)
(laughter)
- Gabriel Anderson, what happened?
You saw it.
- I was going to get
your sweater in a hotel--
(mumbling)
(laughter)
Go ahead.
- You left your sweater at a
hotel, I was going to get it.
You'd sent out some
tweet, I got 60 emails.
Gabe was one of the five I
responded to, and it was good.
- We've all been on the other
side of that transaction now
which is why it's so funny.
(laughter)
- Right, 'cause you're now
like, VaynerBeta's here!
If you wanna spend $20,000 a month,
Gabe is gonna change your life!
- And the onslaught of
inbound that comes in.
It's just trying to pick the seed out of,
the needle out of the haystack.
Basically, I hopped on a
Skype interview with this guy,
Vikash, back in the day.
He's not important.
I lied to Vikash.
I told Vikash I was gonna
be in New York on business,
why don't I just stop by the office?
Meet Gary, do the whole thing.
- You weren't gonna be on business.
You were coming for a job.
- I wasn't coming for a job.
Here's the thing that
I don't think you know.
In the back of my head I thought, well,
Gary's kind of big in startups,
and maybe I can raise some money from him.
- [Gary] I'm gonna slide in there.
- He just needs to see what
we've been doing for the last
couple of years and how we've
been growing and scaling.
It was a whole thing.
I go into the office,
it was, like, at noon.
I'd just gotten into New
York the night before
at, like, one AM.
I was on the red eye or whatever,
I'm completely bloodshot.
I sit down and I've got
this whole thing in my head
that I'm ready to start
talking with him about.
The first thing he asks me is,
"Tell me about your family.
"Tell me about your dad."
Completely throws me off.
I had no clue that was coming.
You talked to me about the
future, what VaynerMedia was,
what you were building,
what it was gonna look like
in the next three to four years.
All these large CMOs
started really figuring out
what social was, and not
just this gamified thing.
Having been here now, I
know that it was true.
But yeah, my whole thing was,
I think I can raise money from Gary,
and then he gives me a
job offer on the spot,
and I was like, oh, shit.
- On the spot.
(laughter)
It was a much better company back then.
Now there's process, and
Alex Klein, and Green Man.
I don't know what the
fuck this company's doing.
The way it was better was,
weird guy Gabe walks in.
(Gabe laughs)
His dad's, like, jazz or something.
He told me some story about
high school or college
when they were doing something
that felt entrepreneurial.
I'm like, I like his laugh.
I'm like, "Fuck it, you want a job, bro?"
That's literally how it went down.
- Yeah, so I don't think
you knew the full thing.
- Now let's go to the part I
always start the show with.
We'll go back to the ladies.
What are you obsessed with right now?
This can be, like, your
sweater, this show on Netflix,
the wigs that you wear.
It doesn't have to be, like, world peace.
Very weird and narrow, or
just actually what, you know,
this new waffle place, this new friend.
I want this to be quite
broad and interesting.
I'm always fascinated by what somebody
is obsessed with right now.
What are you obsessed with right now?
- Currently my obsession is
YouTube and vegan lifestyle,
to be honest.
- Okay, keep going.
- You're in the right place.
- Yeah, no, it's so funny.
It's like, the older I
get, the more sensitive
my body becomes to everything in life.
I was a pescatarian for a
while, and then all of a sudden
I was a vegetarian, and then
I was doing a lot of research
on YouTube about Dr. Sebi and
his teachings and all of that
and how the more healthy it is
to be alkaline and all that.
I was like, you know what?
Let me just change up my whole eating.
- When did this start, Arabella?
- Maybe three weeks ago.
- Good for you.
- (laughs) Three weeks ago.
- [Gary] Good luck.
- So yeah, every day I'm researching
on YouTube about vegan lifestyle.
- Well, you've got the right--
- And you don't know who I am?
I'm offended.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Rich, she's three weeks in!
- Three weeks?
- Yeah, three weeks!
- I mean, it's gonna take
her at least another seven.
- Based on the way I see
you executing your content,
it's gonna take her another
seven and a half weeks.
(laughter)
(crosstalk)
- I go to conferences every
day, I meet people every day,
and I'm like, "What do you do?"
They're like, "Oh, I work
in a social media agency."
I'm like, "Cool, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk."
They're like, "Cool, what do you do?"
I'm like, fuck.
(laughter)
I'm like, this shit is hard out here!
It is hard out here!
Don't feel sad, Rich.
So, that's what you're
obsessed with currently.
- Yes.
- Love it.
- On the macro, the vegan
lifestyle thing is my obsession.
I've been doing it for 11 years.
- Rich, don't.
- We can talk.
- You'll do that off PodSessions.
You're officially, you
personally, right now,
like, a new pair of shoes.
- [Rich] In the micro, in the micro?
- Only in the micro.
- Obsessed with Will Smith on Instagram.
- [Arabella] Oh, yeah, oh my God.
- Incredible what he's doing.
- He's just being authentic.
- It's so cool to see a
guy like that, A list,
not just dip his toe into social media,
but completely embrace it.
- Brother, this is the game.
Drake, last night on Twitch.
Will vlogging and being
on Instagram, it's over.
People don't get it.
It went upside down.
It's over.
- It's gonna be interesting
to see who's gonna be next.
Like, who's paying attention
to Will Smith in that arena?
- Let me save you time.
Somebody like the Rock or
Kevin Hart or this and that,
other people that are As that get
what the fuck's actually happening.
- [Rich] The Rock's already there.
- Yeah, but I mean, what
Will's doing is acting more
like somebody who's
coming from the bottom.
- Correct.
- That's why you like it.
Will's acting like the way we all act.
Like, starting from the bottom.
That's what's so interesting about Will.
He's authentic, like Juju
Smith, like he's doing a vlog.
When you feel it coming from the bottom
from when somebody's at the
top, that's the brain twist.
You get an A list couple right
now in Hollywood to actually
start vlogging on YouTube the
way the family vlogs do it,
it will batshit explode the whole world.
Give me any couple right now
that's on People Magazine
or Us Weekly, any of them.
Fuckin' Blake and fuckin' Gwen Stefani.
If they actually started
vlogging on YouTube
the way the family vloggers
that are crushing it do it,
like, for real for real,
the internet would explode.
The same way it did last night
when Drake went into Twitch.
This is what happens.
But here's the more interesting part.
It's over in my brain, in
the same way that I told Gabe
five and a half years ago, it played out.
In my brain, that's the
only thing that exists.
For me, I'm not even that
curious of who's next for me
'cause it's default, it's
going to be everyone,
'cause it's the cost of
entry of being relevant
in our society in a decade.
- Yeah, but not everyone is
gonna be as talented as Will is.
- Well, that's right,
but there'll be a lot
of fuckin' people that
are talented enough.
Because just vlogging your life
is documenting, not creating.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the micro.
On the macro, I think what's
really cool that's happening
right now is seeing young
people socially activated.
- Yesterday was bonkers, bonkers!
- It's incredible what
is happening right now.
- [Gary] But that's what we need.
- These kids raised with these
tools who are putting them
into motion in a way that
adults don't understand
and shifting not just culture
but political conversation.
- Yeah, it's really great.
And now these fuckers better vote.
To me, I'm like, you fucking fuckers.
Marching out of school is
fucking fun, you miss school.
Being a keyboard warrior on Twitter
and roasting some politicians, fun.
You better get your ass out there.
You wanna really fucking fuck shit up?
If you're turning 18 before
November, fucking go.
Don't pick fucking
Twitch over registering.
Get your shit together.
I'm dying to see what happens,
18 to 22, this November,
'cause that's the game.
This is how I think about social media.
You can be watching my content
or listening to your podcast
or watching Will Smith,
but if you're not doing it
for yourself, you're
getting nothing out of it.
You could be marching and
making a sign and roasting
somebody on Twitter, but
if you don't fuckin' vote,
you fuckin' suck, kid.
- [Rich] (laughs) Correct.
- Gabe, what are you obsessed with?
- Um, tracking my biomarkers.
It's become a recent obsession.
- I don't even know what a biomarker is.
Sounds like some health shit.
- [Arabella] Please elaborate.
- I did my 23 (mumbling) last year,
and then I married that
with my microbiome.
I use this company called WellnessFX.
They do blood draws.
- So, when are you dying?
(laughter)
- I'm gonna live forever.
- I feel like I might too.
- Yeah, I think it's very plausible.
- That's why I'm recording everything.
(laughter)
I'm gonna be a hologram.
- No, it's cool.
I've customized my vitamin
and supplement intake
based off of my blood draws.
- And?
- My energy levels are super high.
- What about your stretching ability?
'Cause you got exposed in your stretching.
- Yeah, you set me up, by the way.
On the record, I want your
entire community to know
that you set me up (laughs).
- Let's talk about this.
Gabe's like, "Hey, we
should work out together,"
'cause he's a beast, you know,
he's strong and everything.
If you looked at his fuckin'
legs, like, it's there, right?
He's got that ass that,
like, makes you go do shit.
(laughter)
So, he's like--
- We need to spend more time together
so let's work out at my gym.
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,
let's throw some weight man,
"let's do this!"
- I only reacted to him being like, "Yo!"
They think they're tough.
I was like, "Yeah, we should
work out, spend some time."
I knew it was gonna be a stretch day.
Tyler, you were a disaster
on the stretch day.
(Gabe laughs)
Guys, for everybody looking at home,
if I think somebody can
rival, can do more...
Tyler, I think, is in
the same realm as me,
but Gabe, I knew, could
lift more and do more.
My plan always is let...
Is this where you beat me by one?
Did you beat me by one?
Thank god that you can't beat me now.
Yes, it's true.
Two January's ago, she beat me by one,
but now I'll destroy you.
I've progressed.
Stretching is how I kill everybody.
Gabe came and, like, the
first part is, I'll do it,
and I know where I was two
years ago, which was nowhere,
so you know, you see somebody stretching,
I'm doing Spidermans (mumbling).
(laughter)
- [Gabe] I got murdered.
- Yeah, you were so not flexible.
- What's your trainer's name again?
- Jordan.
- Jordan, yeah.
Jordan had me in all kinds of positions
that I just was not ready for.
Actually, I got my spandex on.
I'm, like, ready to go.
I've got my weightlifting shoes on.
I'm ready to put up some real--
- Rich, let's talk about your brand.
What's been happening?
For me, I think, the podcast platform
really took you to the next level.
You, along with Lewis Howes
and Pat Flynn (mumbling),
there was a group of
people that I think about
that weren't me and Tim, that
weren't me and Tony Robbins,
that were the next tier below.
This was your land grab.
When did you start your podcast?
- I started the podcast in late 2012.
- [Gary] Perfect, exactly my point.
- Yeah, to paint a picture of
what it was like back then,
I mean, it was still, you know,
it wasn't cool to have a podcast.
- That's exactly right.
- It was super wonky.
You still had to download
them from your desktop
and pump onto your MP3 player.
It wasn't like I was an early adopter.
They'd been around since,
like, 2006 or something.
- Oh, I remember the first wave.
But you were part of the
early part of the next wave.
- You could do a land grab at that point
and establish yourself.
- That's exactly right.
When did Apple's top 100 chart come out?
Was it there already when you started?
- Yeah, it was there already.
- Were you able to hit it, or no?
- Oh, yeah, right away.
When I look at the number of downloads
I was getting then
versus now, it's insane.
- (mumbling) Tell them.
Let's be authentic here, be honest.
- First couple of weeks,
like, 2,000 maybe.
- [Gary] And now?
- Now, 150 to 250.
- Just by having 2,000, where
would you rank in the top 100?
- Uh, in the top 80s or 90s.
- Not in business, overall or in business?
- Overall, and then top three in health,
which was my category.
- Right, so you were
in the top 100 overall
with 2,000 or so an episode.
How often did you do it?
- Once a week.
- Got it.
Where are we at now, Seth?
- [Seth] We're at 52
with 80,000 an episode.
- 80,000 an episode, how many a month?
- Five million.
Yeah, it's what changes.
- Wow.
To now, once a while I'll
pop into the top 100,
but it's so much harder.
When I look at the downloads, like,
it's much more competitive.
It's cool to have a podcast,
everyone's doing it.
Had I started now, (laughs) I mean,
it wouldn't have happened that way.
- Do you believe that, you
know, obviously you wrote a book
and all this stuff, but
do you believe the podcast
was the quintessential moment that kind of
changed your elevation of your brand?
- Yes, but not, I mean, it took time.
- Well, of course.
(crosstalk)
Everything's a slow build.
- It's the tip of the spear
of everything that I do, yeah.
- Listen, the reason I ask
that and why I made it a point,
I always talk about
under priced attention.
In 2012, podcasts was
He went and land grabbed.
To his point, it didn't take a whole lot
for him to be the leader there,
and this is why I care
about an Alexa Skills.
So many of you listening, like,
actually, if you're in town,
you should come to VoiceCon.
We're doing a really
interesting conference
on May 22nd in New York.
I don't know if you're around.
But for everybody listening,
you need to come to this.
If you ask me, hey Gary, I'm
like the three of us, right?
Personality, wanna build stuff.
Everyone's like, "How do I speed it up?
"How do I take a shortcut?"
There is no shortcut.
Even you said right away.
Hey, before anything
else, it took a long time.
But the only prayer to have
a shortcut by human standards
is to win on the newest platform
that's about to become the platform.
Your Alexa skill every morning
around meditation, health, vegan life.
If there was a (mumbling)
tip of the day that was
the dominant Alexa skill three
years from now when she was
three weeks in, you
would've already been known.
- [Alexa] Skills can help
you do lots of things.
- There it goes.
(laughter)
- She knows.
Alexa, stop.
That's the little thing for that.
That's why I'm passionate about that.
That was it for you.
How about for you?
- What was the question, Gary? (laughs)
- What was the platform?
Was Instagram the platform you popped on?
- Yeah, yeah, it was.
- I mean, I see you there.
Are you strong in any platform
besides Instagram yet?
- Instagram and Snapchat is poppin'.
- How many views are you
getting on Snapchat, roughly?
- Over 6,000.
- Good for you.
- Yeah.
- And so you're at, what,
two, 300,000 on Instagram?
- I'm at a little over 330 something.
- And how many comments are
you getting per post, roughly?
- Comments, probably in the hundreds.
No, it's in the thousands on some of them.
- And are you jumping in
there, replying to a bunch?
- Oh yes, that's vital (laughs).
You know what's funny?
I don't know why, but
you know, a lot of people
that are really popular on social media,
I understand if you're in the millions
you can't get to everybody,
but for some reason,
I found out through
conversing with other people
that are popular on social media,
they don't like to talk
back to their followers.
And I'm like, you're crazy.
- [Gary] I agree.
- My followers, that's
what makes the brand.
- That orange book right
there, which is my second book
after me establishing what it all is,
is still the reason I think, like, I mean,
I'm running an 800 person,
$200 million company.
(mumbling)
I feel real good where I sit
in the I'm busy category.
I'm programmed from six AM to 11 PM.
Gabe, watch this.
Gabe's running probably the division
I'm most excited about
in the whole company.
Gabe, how many minutes
have we spent together
in the last six months?
- Yeah, uh, very few.
- [Gary] Go ahead, take a guess.
I don't fucking know, what do you think?
- Less than two hours.
- I mean, like, what the fuck?
Your whole life is being an influencer,
and you don't have time to
fucking answer comments, I do?
Like, fuck you.
- Yeah, I actually feel slightly insulted
if I actually slide in somebody's
DMs that's lower than mine
on some business stuff--
- And they don't reply.
- [Arabella] And they don't reply, no!
I'm like, you've gotta be kidding me.
I'm not in the millions, but you know,
it's only a matter of time.
- And you've got me, and we're doing it.
- [Arabella] Yeah, and I was like,
that's fuckin' ridiculous.
- You know what's funny?
Somebody said something to me at Cannes.
I was at Cannes, the
advertising festival, last year.
Cheddar, Jon Steinberg's
got a business, kind of,
CNBC of the future show,
and I went to do 15 minutes with him.
It's hard to get around Cannes.
You've gotta walk, traffic,
it's just, whatever.
I get there right on time,
and he just looks at me
and he goes, "Fuck," and I go, "What?"
He goes, "You know, we've
programmed 15 people today."
And he goes, "The three
biggest people are you,
"Mark Cuban, and Martin
Sorrell," who owns WPP,
the biggest advertising
agency in the world.
And he goes, "You three
have all been on time.
"The other 12 fuckers are
like, the VP of Google Ads,
"or the VP of, like, future
Twitter activities, and these
"fuckers are 30 minutes late
and think they're somebody."
It really struck with me,
it really struck with me.
It's interesting, that's
where you're going with that.
It's how I sniff out winners
and losers real fast.
- Yeah.
- Real fast.
The number one tell for me
of a loser is the second
I meet you and the first
hour, if I ever have, like,
when I say a loser, I mean
somebody that's actually winning
but deep down, I know they
have no shot long term.
If I break bread like
this, or we have dinner.
When I met Rich, I
remember this very vividly.
If you complain in the first hour
I meet you, you're finished.
I think complaining is the tell.
And if you ask me right now
what's going on with my content,
there's a really interesting vibe going on
'cause it must be the
cadence of our content,
I am getting so much content
from people that are happy,
out of depression right
now, and I cannot tell you
how many of them are completely predicated
on the fact that they
don't make excuses anymore
and they've taken 100% accountability.
I genuinely think it's
the unlock of happiness.
When you think it's all your
fault, what you realize is that
nobody is in control, and
all of sudden you get happy.
It's super interesting.
Anyway, Gabe, what's
going on with, you know,
we live public lives, you don't.
(laughter)
You're the normal--
- I'm the normal, yeah.
- On the normal front,
where are you right now with social media?
What's your favorite platform,
are you using anything?
What is your relationship?
You know all these
magazines, the in, the out?
The hot, the cold?
What's the hot, what's the cold?
Who's, in the last six
months, grown with your time
and attention and usage, and
what've you fallen off on,
for Gabe personally?
- Yeah, for me personally,
I probably straddle between
Snapchat and Instagram.
- [Gary] Those are your two spots.
- Those are my two spots.
- [Gary] What's the third, if at all?
- Medium.
- Medium, 'cause you read?
- Yeah, I read.
I'm an aggressive reader.
- [Gary] Where's Twitter?
- Hardly at all anymore.
- How often will you
open your Twitter app?
Once every...
- Once every couple weeks.
- [Gary] Wow.
- Twitter's gotten toxic,
Twitter has gotten real toxic.
- Respect, respect, respect.
- That's why.
- How often will you open
YouTube to consume content?
- I've got a smart TV at home.
I actually jump on YouTube that way.
- [Gary] The new way, like TV.
- We're unplugged, we
don't have cable anymore.
- Of course, what is cable?
What the fuck is cable?
- We do everything through YouTube.
- Fuckin' cable.
- Yeah, our smart TV.
All of our subscriptions.
- Okay, so it's Insta and Snap.
- Insta and Snap.
I hardly ever check in
on Facebook anymore.
- And what's happening with Snap for you?
It's intimate, one on one?
- Snap is just fun.
One on one, yeah.
It's just fun.
- Jokes, or--
- [Gabe] Yeah, jokes.
- How many of your core
people that you talk with?
- I've probably got 12 people.
- Core.
- Pretty consistent.
- [Gary] And are you going to discover
and looking at any of that content?
- Hardly ever.
- Got it.
So, are you consuming people's stories?
- I am, yes.
- [Gary] Insta?
- Insta is, I just
enjoy, I think, a lot of
my Facebook friends, I don't
check in on Facebook anymore,
but a lot of my Facebook
friends are there,
so I can just catch up--
- And outside your friends,
what do you follow on Insta?
Influencers, media companies?
- I'm doing gymnastic
strength training these days
so I follow a lot of the older
gymnasts and their stuff.
- A couple of booty girls
and some hot chicks?
(laughter)
- Yeah, of course, I mean.
- There's nothing wrong with that.
- From my 20s, from my 20s.
- Yeah, right, the old days.
- Yeah, the old days.
It's hard to unfollow.
(laughter)
- It's hard to hit that button.
What about media sites,
will you follow NBA or CNN
or anything like Fox, or?
- Nah, I mean, nah.
- What about me, do you follow me?
- Of course.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I watch this show every day.
(laughter)
- Rich, yeah.
Rich, what about you with social media?
You're coming from a
different perspective.
Actually, let's start with this.
The breakdown between
a business perspective
and it's just really Rich
had you never had this life,
the old lawyer Rich, what's
your breakdown of percentages
of the public versus you
actually using it as a private
vehicle in any shape or
form, what's the breakdown?
- Well, I'm sharing on most of
them except for Snapchat now.
I'm still romantic about Twitter.
- Real quick, real quick.
Out of 100 points, when you
use all these platforms,
is it 100% the professional
version of yourself?
Do you have any actual human interaction?
Like, your normal self.
I don't, so I do not use any social media
like a normal person.
I started it as business.
I never grew up with it as social.
My texting is my only human place.
I don't hit up my friends on social.
I don't follow them on social.
I don't have a real
life with social media.
It's always been business,
it's always been Gary Vee.
That's always been the way it was,
so I don't even know the alternate.
Do you have a normal life on Facebook,
or on Twitter, or on Snap like Gabe does?
- Yeah, absolutely, and for me--
- [Gary] And what percentage
is normal versus business?
- It's difficult for me to differentiate
between the two because my personal life
is so blended with my professional life.
- Mine as well, ish, but
you know what I mean, right?
- [Rich] Yeah, I know what you
mean, I know what you mean.
- Do you have an interaction with somebody
that is not for public domain?
- Of course, of course.
- Like, "Hey, I'll pick
up the kids at 4.30,"
or, "Did you see the game tonight?"
The only place I'll do that is text.
- I'll do that on Twitter,
I'll do that on Twitter.
And I'll do that on Instagram
with just daily life stories
and then I'll communicate
with friends on DM also
on Instagram and Twitter.
- So, what's emerging for
you, and what's declining?
Hot, cold.
- Well, Instagram is very hot.
That's where I get the highest engagement.
Cold is Twitter, although
it's still my favorite,
'cause I'm romantic about it, you know?
It's still what I go to
first even though I get
the least amount of engagement
there, and I love it.
I follow news and stuff
like that on there as well.
- Arabella?
- What was the question again?
I'm just so deep into the conversations,
I'm like, okay, what?
- [Gary] Hot, cold.
- Hot for me is definitely Instagram.
Second hottest would be Snapchat.
Coldest is probably YouTube.
- You're just not paying attention?
- No, no, when you say hot,
I'm on YouTube as in looking,
I'm on it every day, but as
far as uploading content,
that's what I'm not doing.
- Understood.
- Yes.
- Gabe, who's the most interesting person
out there to you right now?
Macro, macro conversation.
- [Gabe] Macro?
- Like, who's the most
interesting person right now?
It could be one of these
gymnasts if you're into it.
Who are you, like, oh shit, I
just discovered this person.
I like what they're doing,
or I'm learning from them,
or I like the way they're doing it.
Yours, probably, could
be Will again, Rich.
- I really like Aubrey Marcus
right now, CEO of Onnit.
I think, he's got his new book coming out.
- Do you know that we have a
real, real, real relationship?
Is that how you first discovered him,
or you knew him before that?
- I knew him from the Onnit
days, the Joe Rogan podcast
back in those days, five, six years ago.
- [Gary] So, you're about him.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm in that demo.
- I totally understand.
Rich, besides Will, anybody else?
Or is it Will?
- I mean, Will is probably
at the top right now,
front of mind, but I follow all
different kinds of accounts.
I like StreetArtGlobe.
I'm into art and I think
what's going on with that
account is super creative,
so that comes to mind.
- [Gary] Arabella?
- Honestly, I look at your stuff a lot.
- When did you first discover my stuff?
- Like, two years ago.
- Oh, really?
- It's funny how,
I'm all big about, you know,
the universe, wanting--
- Manifesting?
- Yes!
- You're like, I'm gonna meet this guy!
- Yeah, I had that in my mind.
It doesn't take a lot to manifest.
I'm really big on, once I want something,
it's going to happen.
It's only a matter of time.
- What do you want to happen?
Do you want to be the
biggest actress in the world?
- I will be the biggest,
one of the biggest actresses in the world.
- And how do you define that?
Do you define that as
getting paid $30 million
to do a feature film?
- No, it's like--
- I'm not talking about the money,
but I'm trying to, forget about that.
Do you mean that by being
the number one leading lady
for the biggest films in the world?
- [Arabella] Yes.
- You'll get paid $30 million by the way.
That's what would happen.
- A lot of people say
that, but when it comes,
like you talk about doing
the work all the time,
they don't wanna do the work.
- Do you think you can do that in New York
or do you feel you have
to eventually move to LA?
- I don't know, because I feel
like when the time is right,
LA will come calling for me.
- Do you think you'll get there
before the OTT environment?
The way the internet...
Let me ask you a question.
Let's ask a roundabout
question, everybody answer this.
Do you believe the biggest film in America
15 years from today, which is
quite a while but not really.
Especially for the kids at home.
It goes fast, right Rich?
- Absolutely.
- 15 years from now, do you
believe the biggest film,
like, the Black Panther
15 years from today,
do you think that is being
executed in movie theaters
the way they are now, and
maybe the movie theaters
have a little bit of a better
setup and maybe the food
is better, but like, we
all go to a physical place
that basically looks like the theater.
Gabe, you go first.
15 years.
- No way.
VR, I mean, like, 15
years, that's a long time.
That basically puts us in the 20, 30s.
There's no way we're gonna be going--
- [Gary] So, your answer is no.
Rich?
- I think we'll still be in transition.
I think there'll still be
theaters there, but as the--
- The number one film.
- The number one film, I think,
will still be in a theater
but that's waning days, you know?
As a father of a 10 year old girl--
- I get it, but it's gonna hold on.
(crosstalk)
- There's something about
the public experience,
I think, that's still valid.
- I get it, Arabella?
- I believe it's in motion already,
because films, and just writing
it takes, sometimes, years.
- I get it, but do you
think the number one film
in 2033 is being distributed
on its $4.9 billion in revenue,
Star Wars 70 fuckin' three--
- Distributed, no.
There's probably another
platform not even created yet
that it's gonna be distributed on.
- Yeah, I think my answer is
a little bit closer to Rich's.
I actually think VR is
gonna take some real time,
though I think 15 starts becoming
right around the interesting zone.
I mean, the best part is, we're
gonna be able to watch this.
This is why I love what
my life's about now.
Man, I've been thinking a lot.
I'm gonna bounce off for a second.
Boy, do I wish I had the film.
Do you know the first time
I went to Twitter's office,
the whole company, there
was six people in there?
There are more people in
this room right now than when
I visited Twitter, how many
employees the company had.
You know how cool that vlog would be?
Or like, when I spoke to
the entire Facebook company.
Or the film (mumbling)
passing on Uber twice?
That'd be cool.
Or when Boyd used to sleep in the office.
(laughter)
Did (mumbling) ever come through?
(mumbling)
- Mac Miller?
- Yeah, Mac Miller came.
(mumbling)
Nipsey, way back then.
- Future.
Tity Boi, 2 Chainz now.
Just all these moments.
Or when you came to the office.
Right now, my content in
five years is gonna be able
to have you say that
and they're gonna edit
that clip from DailyVee
113 when you walked in.
It's super rad.
Anyway, back to films.
It'll be interesting.
The reason I'm asking you is,
I think you'll have to go to LA unless...
What's really interesting is
that the Hollywood of the east
is clearly now Atlanta.
- Mmhmm.
- Do you know what's going on
with the outskirts of Atlanta, Georgia?
- [Arabella] I don't know what's going on.
- Let me tell you.
Marvel, a lot of--
- [Arabella] Oh, yeah, that.
- They're filming these
movies now in Atlanta.
- [Arabella] Right, right.
- There's these studios, and
I don't remember the town.
They're about an hour outside of Atlanta.
But Georgia, because of the tax benefits,
is stealing and building.
I mean, Atlanta is--
- Tyler Perry built--
- That's exactly right, and Marvel,
I know that Marvel is
doing a bunch of stuff.
I'm 100% sure that VaynerMedia
will have an office in Atlanta.
100, not 99.
It will happen.
- Yeah, I came from Atlanta.
That's a hotspot, but I came up here
specifically for training.
- I get it.
- What a lot of people
don't understand is,
I was in Atlanta and
that's cool for little
independent artists, not
trying to belittle anybody.
- No, it's a New York, LA game.
Yeah, it's New York, LA game.
- People take you more seriously.
Hm?
- [Gary] Are you getting
value, is it working?
- What do you mean?
- [Gary] Are you learning?
- Oh, yes, yes, and I'm
actually already meeting actors
that are in this area that
find me on social media.
Like, these are real actors, so (laughs).
- And they're looking for real attention,
and that's the game, that's the trade.
- Basically, I came up here
to get that good NYC training
so they can say, "Hey,
Arabella, we see your resume
"and we see that you're serious.
"You have training here, here, here."
I have training in Atlanta,
I have training in Augusta,
I have training from LA, but
now when I come to New York
and say, "Hey, I have this on my resume,
"I'm this very serious actor,
here's everything I have."
That's when they're gonna be like,
"Okay, we know you are a lead role
"because you trained for a lead."
- Your Instagram account, what
was the first popping moment?
What content, what collab, what happened?
You're doing your thing,
you're putting out content.
- Honestly, I did not start
taking Instagram seriously
until about a year and a half ago.
- [Gary] What happened?
- I went viral about
three times, WorldStar.
Shout out to WorldStar (laughs).
- [Gary] Shout out to
WorldStar from me too.
- Yeah, shout out to WorldStar.
WorldStar put me on the
map, I'm not even gonna lie.
I was shocked.
I was actually filming
two films two years ago
at the same time, and
then after I was done,
there was nothing else lined up,
so I'd hit up one of these
comedians on Instagram.
I was like, "Hey, I like
your work," or whatever.
- [Gary] On Instagram
or on Vine at the time?
- No, no, no, Instagram, Instagram.
I was like, "I like
your work," or whatever.
I was like, nobody knows that I'm funny.
I think I'm funny.
I was like, "I like your
stuff, so let's just meet up
"and just make some skits,"
and he was like, "Okay, cool."
So, we met up--
- [Gary] Did you have any
followers at that point?
- I had a little bit.
- How much?
- Maybe, like, 17 thousand.
So, I met up with him, and
then I was, like, okay--
- [Gary] Can we give him a shout out?
- Yeah, yeah, um.
- [Gary] Do you remember?
- Yeah, I remember.
I haven't worked with him for a while.
Mr Phreeze, yes, Mr Phreeze.
We worked together.
The first video was
called I Want Some Dick.
(laughter)
- Yeah, I've heard of it.
- [Arabella] Basically,
we just put it out there.
- [Gary] Have you seen that, Gabe?
- No, no.
- Oh, well you should.
All of the comedy is still on there.
When we put it out there, I had no idea
that it was gonna go viral.
It didn't even go viral,
it went mega viral.
It went really popular
on my page and his page
and once WorldStar got it, it was like--
- It went everywhere.
- Yeah, it was crazy.
After that, the next--
- [Gary] You're like, wait a minute.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I was like, hmm.
And then the next two
videos went viral again.
Every time I made something it went viral.
I guess 'cause I'm extra.
But I'm just a good
actress like that (laughs).
But it was just comedy,
so I didn't really take it that seriously.
- Good for you.
- But once I started getting so many views
and then people started paying attention,
people started asking me questions.
I already have an entrepreneur
side that's very strong.
I was like, hmm, let me start doing it.
- What about the wigs?
I know when I looked at your
account back when I first,
like, what's that about?
Is that real life?
Is that part of it?
- I just love looking
different all the time.
You know, I'm naturally spacey
and artsy and out there.
- [Gary] Babin is too.
(laughter)
- So, any time I see something that's,
oh, that's so unicorn-like.
Everybody knows me as
the original unicorn,
'cause that's what I am.
If I see it and I'm like,
that's unicorn-like,
I have to get it.
- You feel like you're
the original unicorn?
That felt like Paris Hilton
saying she invented the selfie
and then the internet beat her up.
- (laughs) I never heard her say that.
When I say that, I have
confidence in myself
as a woman being just mystical
and something that
you've never seen before.
- But you feel there's no
mystical woman before you?
- No, of course there was.
- [Gary] Well then, you
wouldn't be the original.
- Did you bring any wigs with you?
- Huh?
- Did you bring any wigs?
- Oh, no, no, I didn't.
I wanted to come as natural
as possible (laughs).
- Rich, what's going on with you, man?
What do you wanna ask us?
What do you wanna ask the audience?
What are you up to, what
are you thinking about?
What's your next move?
How are you thinking about things?
- I've got a couple books coming
up that are being released.
I rewrote Finding Ultra, and
that's coming out this week
which is what brought me to New York.
And honestly, Gary, you
know, I'm just working on
being better and better every day.
Unlike you, I've never had
a viral moment, you know?
It's just been progressive, slow growth.
- You know what's funny?
You know what's funny?
I really haven't had
a viral moment either.
Believe this or not.
I've had a lot of things
do extremely well,
but I don't have any video on
YouTube with over 10 million.
You agree with me, Babin, right?
Rich, it's really funny.
I don't think I've had a viral moment.
I've had a lot of good things going.
And if it's a viral moment like WorldStar,
that I've had some stuff,
but I haven't had anything.
Go get Andy, I wanna hear
Andy's perspective on this.
- Monday Morning is the
only one that I would...
(mumbling)
- [Man] And when you
graduate college, that video.
- No, I've had some videos that've really,
Andy's gonna be able to...
Andy, have I ever gone viral?
- [Andy] Yes.
- Like, what do you consider viral?
You mean, the big, like,
400 Trillion to One
and the Monday Morning?
Would we consider those viral?
What's the most viral
thing that I've had happen?
- 30 million views, 400 Trillion to One.
- That went 30 million?
- That's pretty viral.
- That feels viral.
(laughter)
- Alright Andy, you can leave now.
- But here's what I wanna
say, here's what I wanna say.
Gary, you're 40?
- Two.
- 42, alright.
I'm 51, right?
I'm the elder statesman here.
- [Gary] Fuck, I'm so old.
But here's the thing.
(chatter)
I didn't even--
- I liked when you went
back and you were, like,
completely clean shaven and bald.
When you brought back hair, I
thought that was a good move.
Go ahead, Rich.
- [Rich] You totally shaved your head?
- Not totally shaved,
but I kept it real light.
(crosstalk)
- Completely let it, cut it down.
- He went 360 of this.
Two years ago, he was clean.
- But here's my point.
- And I was dirty.
- I didn't even start,
really, this journey
that I'm on right now
until I was older than you.
- [Gary] Yeah, no, I get it.
- For anybody who's listening or watching,
if you feel like it's too late--
- Tell 'em, Rich.
- It's fucking bullshit.
I had a whole past life that
led me to a point that created
a health crisis and an
existential crisis about what
I was doing, and some
confusing years about trying
to figure out how I wanted
to move forward in the world.
As I said in Crushing It,
your work has been influential
in not just motivating me,
but providing me with tools
to really assess that for myself.
- And Rich, on that note,
oh, I'm sorry, please finish.
- Yeah, let me just finish
this thought, which is,
my life is an embarrassment
of Riches right now,
but it's really a function
of hard work and patience
and diligence and being really
dedicated to the process
and being detached from the results.
- Rich, that's exactly, dude.
I couldn't say it better.
Dude, it's the fuckin' process.
You will look back, when
you become the biggest,
when you put that fuckin'
star in Hollywood,
I promise you, when you're
sitting with, you know,
the grandchildren or
people that look up to you,
you're gonna romance about this time
way more than the fuckin' hits.
- [Rich] Yeah, of course.
- [Gary] The process is the fucking drug.
- What do you think back on?
I've done these crazy
ultra endurance races,
but I don't think about
crossing the finish line.
I think about that day I
didn't wanna get out of bed.
That's what gives it meaning for me.
In terms of your question of, like,
what is the question I
wanna ask the audience,
everything that I've been able
to accomplish is a function
and direct result of investing in trying
to more deeply connect with myself.
My question to the audience
really is, like, who are you?
Who the fuck are you?
If you can't answer that
question honestly for yourself,
you can pick a goal and you
can be motivated by Gary
and take advantage of the
tools he puts out in the world,
but you might be climbing a ladder
that's leaning up against the wrong wall.
- [Gary] 100%.
- You really need to take
the time to step back
and really get to know who you are.
- Taste, I call it taste.
- What is your unique design?
What is it that gets you
out of bed and excited?
If you can be super honest
about that and crack the veneer
of denial and all these
things that hold you back,
that is the path forward.
But if you wanna just leapfrog over that
because you think that's
an inconvenience--
- [Gary] You're finished.
- Yeah, you can chase stuff
your whole life but you're never
gonna be a fully
integrated, authentic person
and you're never gonna
achieve your potential
and you're never gonna be
able to share what it is
that is most valuable, not just
to yourself, but to whoever
happens to be paying attention
to whatever you're doing.
- Gabe, what's going on with beta?
- In what sense?
- I feel like,
we feel like, I feel and you feel,
we've finally got a grasp on this.
This was a company that was incapable.
VaynerMedia was incapable of
taking the $300,000 a year
that tens of thousands of
people wanna give VaynerMedia
because of me, because we
were built for the Budweisers,
and the Chases, and the
biggest companies in the world.
Gabe was a unique individual
in the organization
that was always entrepreneurial.
We did publishing things together.
I felt that you were the man for the task.
I would argue the first year
we were still trying to figure it out.
It's the machine, and I feel
like, what has happened,
this is almost like, weirdly,
me having my own meeting.
What happened, do you think,
six months ago, or nine months?
And what have you learned from the SMBs
and the mid market companies?
What's happening?
What's the nut that
you've been able to crack
as a leader of that department?
I actually think it's a very big...
I would argue that 35% of people
that are listening to this
podcast right now actually
wanna do what you're doing.
Which is, they wanna be a
service provider or an influencer
for small and medium sized businesses
and build their business,
so it's really interesting.
Whereas, you were really
like, "Oh shit, Gabe's funny
"and laughs loud, let me put
him in this seat right now."
What Rich just did was
brought a ton of value,
reinforcing something I think
that is our joint religion.
I literally thought I was just talking.
What's interesting is I
think you might be able
to give an insight that
could change somebody's life.
A ton of these kids are
building their own agencies
or services or things of that nature.
What was that nut that you cracked?
- I think, one, I really
give a fuck about these guys
and girls that are out
there building companies.
I've walked in their shoes.
You do as well, and you
give me a lot of leeway
to try to figure it out
and taste and try things
and experiment and be able to experiment
without being in fear of,
well, what's the (mumbling),
are we making money, what's happening?
But really trying to figure out,
what do these businesses need?
I've been in their shoes before.
How do we add a lot of value?